if you are ready to put your best face
forward while turning back time it is
time to experience
the honeycomb laser skin treatment i'll
take you to blue point medical spot to
show you this
amazing treatment
one of the most popular treatments right
now is the honeycomb
laser treatment it is fantastic to help
your skin take years off of it actually
jennifer quinn is here from blue point
medical spa
this is this is one of your specialties
tell us about the honeycomb laser
treatment
well the honeycomb laser treatment is
designed to
soften the surface of the skin it helps
to even out the tones
it can minimize pores and help with sun
damage as well
i've actually had this treatment done
here at blue point medical spawn if you
look right now
at the patient what's interesting about
this treatment is
the texture of the skin immediately
changes and that's where honeycomb
laser treatment comes because it kind of
looks like a honeycomb right
yep it's creating tiny little honeycomb
burns
on the tissue and what that does it
helps to resurface
the skin to make it more of an even tone
and to make the skin brighter now
it goes down deep underneath is it what
is it doing producing collagen in there
yes it's producing collagen it's
creating new
skin cells and it helps to with
premature aging
and also to tighten the skin and it's
also great
for acne as well
especially with the mask that we're
wearing it can diminish
acne scars and it helps with
drying out the actual acne as well how
many treatments
until you start to notice a difference
well it usually is the first one you
start seeing some results and then it
gets better as we
continue the treatment i'm actually on
treatment number three and i will say i
noticed
immediately right now she looks great
but in a few hours
she may be turning another color what's
going to happen yes
after the treatment the patient will be
kind of red irritated for about a day
and then the next day they'll be kind of
pink
and they'll notice their skin's kind of
rough and the texture is
kind of tight and they'll start peeling
about the third and fourth day
yeah the results once you get the peel
done are fantastic
let's talk about safety protocol here at
blue point medical spa
what are you doing to make patients feel
good about coming out and getting their
treatments done
well each client has scheduled an
appointment of course we have them
spread apart
we have you know 15 minutes in between
that we're
you know cleaning the cleaning the rooms
we also
spray the rooms three times a week as
well
what kind of a special do you have right
now right now
we have our treatments for 220
per treatment and that is for the faith
neck and chest okay there you go the
honeycomb laser treatment
220 dollars it's well worth the money
the results
speak for themselves and only at blue
point medical spa
blue point medical spa is located at
3320 north buffalo drive suite 103. you
can give them a call
at 702-307-3330 to make your appointment
or visit them online at
bluepointmedicalspa.com and
take advantage of their special
honeycomb laser treatment the face and
neck area for 220
jc